all right margaret
yes margaret where'd you grow up where
are you from el centro california
el centro where's el centro and by india
in palm springs and tell me about your
childhood both
with your parents um
i lived with my mom and dad till i was
four years old
and then from four on up well
i was sitting on my mom's house when i
was four years old and i saw my dad
shoot him killer and
um from 4
to 13
413 i kept getting raped by my uncles
my older cousins and my dad
i kept getting beat by my grandmother by
her stitching cords
and then i got pregnant at 13.
and um had a home abortion
at 14 i was trying to commit suicide
and they sent me to a state hospital
and i would try to kill myself in there
and
try to kill and hurt other
staff members
when i was 15
i had got out of the state hospital i
got out and
got raped by police and my
brother-in-law killed him
you rather killed the cop killed the top
in san bernardino
because i got raped by them and then i
got pregnant again
and i had my own not a home abortion but
just regular abortion
at 17 i had my own apartment
and i was with the older guy like i was
17 he was like 39 and i was
always having all the guys because i
looked it up to them
and i respected them um
i started having sex when i was nine
years old
because i just felt that there was
something to do
and then i was sexually active from 9 to
18 i was having sex like constantly
like every day like at least 30 days 30
times a day
when i was 19 i got into porn
until i was 25 i did porn
that's it that's a lot yeah
so when your parents your dad went to
prison i assume yeah he went to prison
for four years he claimed something to
say
insane or something so he only did four
years
and who who raised you my grandmother
after that you're with your grandmother
my grandmother and my grandfather
and my grandma kept beating on me and
she just let my uncle
rape me what a childhood
how do you i mean all of this must have
affected you as an adult so
without ptsd uh severe ptsd
i have flashbacks and nightmares about
it every day
you have kids now half war and did you
raise them
i raised them until they was old enough
to have them up for open adoption
because i didn't want to go through
abuse relationships
like i did and they wanted them to see
me getting beat
so i get them up for adoption
and now you're living homeless you're in
schedule yes i'm on skid row
here been here for two years living in a
tent
living 10 to 10 and how is that going
for you
not good because i'm selling my body
whatever
i'm not having fun you're still doing it
yep
i mean it seems like that's all you've
known since you were a child right yeah
you can't really do it but i'm getting
paid this time but when i was growing up
i wasn't
but working on skid row you can't be
making a lot i don't
do it on skid row go to hollywood or you
get to hollywood
yep
and you work on your own or with a pimp
i don't work on my own i'm independent
is that is that true yes is that tough
though do you guys
yeah it's kind of tough because you need
someone to protect you and you don't
have that
so because if you if you don't get
protection then what happens
everything can happen to you so you got
to protect yourself you know how to put
your card up
and then what happens with the with your
the guys who pick you up you have
troubles sometimes there too
yeah i do then i put them in check and
then
that's it then they have to follow my
rules how do you pull them to fit in
check
i tell them what what it's going to be
and if they don't do it
do what i tell them to do then it's over
yeah and they say we don't want that
then
they'll start acting right and drugs are
part of your life uh yeah when it comes
to crack
when did it start for you um
2013.
so so you went through all this stuff as
a child and didn't really take to drugs
until
2013. on my birthday my husband
or my second husband gave me eight balls
just about for myself and
i never knew what it was and i smoked
and i liked it so i just started doing
it kept doing it
what's the hardest part of your life and
what you've been through so much
what's the what's the hardest part for
you see my mom
get killed yeah i'm sure did you see it
happen
yeah i was sitting on my mom's lap where
my dad shot and killed her in the head
shot and killed her i was telling my
mom's that one she just slided my lap my
arm
and you're in your 20s and you were
having kids and stuff like that what
were you doing how are you supporting
yourself
oh boy doing poor youtube porn
i was doing porn then i started
stripping
i'm sure there's a connection between
the the sexual abuse you had as a kid
and
your working porn and what you're doing
today right
yes
what what emotion do you deal with the
most
depressing depression
have you have you tried therapy or
anything i tried but i couldn't talk
about my problems
it was hard to tell about my problems
huh i tried i tried to do therapy but it
was hard to talk about problems so i
wouldn't talk about them
you're doing a good job here first
couple men
and how do you view life i mean do you
see life is just a everyone stop for
themselves and everyone's just trying to
take advantage of each other no actually
i was planning on killing myself
on christmas overdosing coming up
because i can't take life no more
have you tried suicide before yes i died
nine times in 2007 when i overdosed
i died nine times and i thought that's
the way to go
overdose with what all different pills
because they got a lot of pills right
now
back then i've taken 900 um 900 pills
and they gave me more pills now so
how are your kids doing good i guess
i want to talk to him i'm i'm like
embarrassed to talk to him
because what i'm going through
but they might ask me what am i doing or
whatever i want to light on
so i want to talk to him
what would help you the most you think
to not be suicidal to not
be so self-destructive to have a good
guy in my life and
that understands me and respects me
have you ever had a good guy in your
life nope all of them was abusive
what kind of abuse of your relationships
right uh
well one lap two years ago he gave me a
black eye
and broke three bones in my eye
and he put me in jail by lying and
saying that i threatened him
but i wasn't even in the area at the
time and so now i got
parole for three years no probation i'm
sorry
probation for three years and i keep
going in and out of jail because of him
lying
and i have a warrant now because he lied
there's nothing i can do about it so you
should actually be back
in jail right now i'm supposed to be in
jail but they're not taking me because
they know
the cover thing
and they know that he was lying so
what what what helped you survive you've
been through so much
uh holi
how old are you 41 i just turned 41
sunday
do you see that so much of all of this
really is is
not none of it's your fault you just
were born into a family that brought you
lots of
headaches and craziness yeah sometimes
it's kind of hard to believe it
sometimes do you have siblings
i have one brother he's
in and out prison for murder
[Music]
don't talk to him no more
have you ever done anything else for
work other than sex work uh
porn stripping i was a manager at a
daycare child's daycare with her
and um i used to uh
work at a um what's called um
some kind of pet thing i think it's pet
a lion or something
alliance and omaha nebraska i used to
work with him for like two years
were you happier when you were doing a
square job no
it was boring to me
[Music]
do you find the work that you're doing
now satisfying or
fulfilling in any way you do yeah
what what what about it works for you uh
takes my edge off
and makes me feel good so it boosts your
self-esteem a little bit
a little bit yeah yeah regulars that
take care of you and
uh yeah
what was the best time of your life uh
when i was 19 when i started doing porn
and looking back at your life is there
anything that
i mean do you have regrets or do you
just see it as you're just surviving i
just regret
being the born you do because my dad
used to always tell me i was a big
old [ __ ] up i should have never been
born and you only made boys and all that
so
i just feel like i shouldn't be more i
should be a girl
what's the most important lesson you've
learned um how to respect myself
more now to be a strong person
you're strong do you feel like you
love and respect yourself somewhat
you're getting better
i'm getting better but i'm getting
strong i'm stronger
what's the worst thing that's happened
to you working the streets like this
um cycling people's throat because they
want to be aggressive
you get some crazy they don't just try
to be aggressive and
i got to prove to them that it's not
going down i slice their throat
with the word
i can remember not to do that to nobody
else you get asked to do things you're
not
comfortable doing all the time yeah
how do you get out of that
just say i don't feel good or
to say i'm a lead or something like that
and then they're changing their mind
do you carry anything to protect
yourself yes nice nice
you've had to use them yes i had
on 10 different guys
i just like see all their throats
how's this out boy
do you have contact with your family
your kids um i try not to because i'm
embarrassed of the way i'm living right
now
yeah shame is a big part of it all isn't
it yeah and i don't want them to know
anything about it
that's why i wanted to die on christmas
i'm sorry that's why i wanted to die on
christmas
i mean how would you die i wanted to
kill myself um overdosing
you want you want to od on christmas
which is
day after tomorrow or day after and
midnight
been like tomorrow night as opposed to
overdose
that's your plan yes
i think i'm gonna get in the in the way
of your plan
i'm gonna try i can't let you do that
i cannot let you do that um
you're you're staying with your sister
yes who i know
green eyes my sister's my my sister's
name is
green eyes and you know my oldest like
10 years older than me is it nice being
with your sister
uh sometimes you don't get drunk and
then she start acting crazy then i have
to act crazy
yeah but she don't want to fight me
because she knows her up
so depression is a thing for you
has to be right yeah and not sleeping
insomnia
are you gonna sleep i don't sleep until
i do crystal
i don't sleep for like three or four
days and then i sleep probably like four
hours and i'm up
the reason you're considering suicide is
just because why you're not sick of life
i think is the way i'm living
i need a better way to live what would
help you
a good man that respects me and
and understands me and
me just being off the streets
what are you doing for christmas uh
nothing
not that i know i'm gonna i'm gonna
kidnap you for christmas okay
make sure you don't commit suicide i
can't i can't let you do that
are you will you will you will you hang
out with me for christmas yes i will
very good
it's a date okay
um have you have you considered suicide
before in your life
yes in 2007 i was raped
and i killed myself like i overdosed
on 900 pills i died nine times and then
come to find out i was pregnant
after they put me in a deuce coma after
i killed like died
put me in a dick's coma so i come to
find out i was pregnant
and did you keep that baby yes because
he didn't do nothing wrong
and he deserved to live like everybody
else like everybody else and
he didn't have to run so i was gonna
take it out on him
he's like a special baby to me
and who's raising him i put him up for
adoption
open adoption um he's with a family in
omaha nebraska do you talk to him at all
uh last time i thought it was two years
ago
when i wasn't on drugs i mean not doing
drugs like i do now but
is is right now the highest point of
your drug use yeah
because i'm out here on the streets yeah
it's a rough life here yeah it's cold
yeah what's the hardest part of your
life now
just the depression and everything being
apart from your kids
this is my kids you guys you've had a
horrible life and not ptsd
have fastbacks and nightmares all every
night and every day i have flashcards
yeah the ptsd
must be severe ptsd
have you ever been alive huh have you
ever been in love
no i try to love people but they always
hurt myself
you always want to beat on me or
whatever said he loved me but
in her lyrical body you won't be able to
handle hanging out with me
why because i'll be nice to you
i don't think you'll know what to do
with it
i've never hit anybody in my life oh
that's good to know
and i'm definitely not going to let you
take two phil you want to take pills is
that how you would do it yes
i'm not going to let you down overdose
do you take pills as well is that it yes
i do it's one of your things for
diabetes seizures asthma
and on low thyroid
high cholesterol heart problems i'm
going to have my hands falling
here for christmas no
well margaret i'm i'm concerned for you
but i'm excited that you're gonna let me
kidnap you from skid row okay for a
little bit
maybe i can talk some sense into you i
hope so
all right well we'll figure out how and
why and when
and all that and okay and uh maybe we'll
do an update one day and see how you are
okay three four months or something like
that right because i'm hoping you're
gonna turn the corner on all this
depression because you deserve a better
life
everybody deserves a great life and you
especially with all the tough breaks
you've had
okay thank you all right
all right what are we for two days but
tomorrow is christmas eve right
yes all right we're gonna figure this
out okay
all
i'm not right let you take pills and
kill yourself okay
you can't do that